hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Anna hmm okay
all right there's been some advice given
out that I should take heed of there's
an iron bar somewhere on the ground here
I was pretty sure that I was thorough in
my investigation of this area but
apparently there's something that I
missed an iron bar of some sort they
didn't say specifically where but they
said it did because I'm really gonna
comb ah there it is okay got it
okay got it all right now next step was
stabbed the offering they said stabbed
the painting but I sort of connected the
dots that you have to it's an offering
Oh
oh that is a heart I should destroy it
oh oh oh what I do what I do
I've heart oh no oh no oh [ __ ] please
the beating oh well someone also said
read it I already read that read this
the note again
okay nothing oh shut up
oh shut up wait hang on no hunting knife
oh no way oh the beating is not okay
there we go
ah large needles what do these do anyway
I don't know what this is
shut up you don't know what anything is
okay so I've got a bunch of these
okay all the beading shut up shut up
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
okay someone else said that I need to
something to fix the stove fixed all X
is still fix the stuff
fix fix cha up part I think I gotta burn
the heart probably gotta burn the heart
Hey Hey burn heart burn the heart right
now [ __ ] hard ah but I don't see
anything this I don't see anything that
could be useful in fixing a stove I
thinking on me no maybe the iron bar is
what needs to be I don't see anything on
the floor here there's nothing on the
floor I've looked everywhere all of the
beating oh let's just go sicko probably
probably got it I probably got it Oh
okay whatever just ah how do i repair
the stove whoa is there something else
in the down here there's something else
all there is there's there's something
else parts oh oh we get me out of here
get me out of em burn it burn the
frigging heart oh not the mobile phone
not two mobile phone oh oh you don't
think it'll work shut up you're an
[ __ ]
why won't it work I need more I figured
if I pray anymore I'll shut up you why
won't this work oh why won't this work
ah [ __ ] art okay okay ah you can how
can this not how can this not be right
how can this not the food the plant food
stuff crap I don't know I'm really
reaching now
I don't know what does it need just need
something for how about sawdust hey no
way come [ __ ] I get out inverter okay ah
what else do I need to burn Oh
oh shut up you frickin heart
how about the decrepit boards can I burn
them please oh oh okay alright there's
got to be some like wood or something to
burn with it for Qantas work
I need something to burn I need
something to burn this
oh come on what the hell is there
anything left down here anything at all
just large needles just large needles
more large needles okay hang on maybe I
maybe I made a mistake
maybe I tried to put the large needle on
top of the other large needle and that's
why it said it was stupid because this
is stupid
no there's enough of them there is it
top it with that I don't get maybe i
heat and then I stab the needle I swear
I thought this would blow the stove door
maybe now I do it nope I don't have a
clear idea hell sawdust here there's
always wood on the floor but none of its
grabbable I need something to burn up
wasting all my time I keep getting stuck
on one thing or another it's just kind
of stupid at this point at this point
it's just kind of stupid
okay Sears I've tried everything in my
inventory on the thing I've tried to
light it in multiple different ways
maybe I need to add the heart oh you
gotta became he was at it
Oh God oh just need to light it okay I'm
there
really oh I'm sorry okay now that I
think about that I should have I should
have realized that sooner that it wanted
me to put the heart in there but oh why
is everything purple pink now
oh not the Attic haha
sure Oh God he's scared the crap out of
me
okay got a mask got a mask nothing
freaky deaky masks oh I see okay
ah is gonna take forever isn't it okay
holy crap
no come on ah ah come on it's glued to
my face what is this Jim Carrey's the
mask yes
why is it glued to my face oh I missed
that I missed it
whatever that was if it was important I
missed it
that mannequin thing why did I have to
put freaking mass efflux okay must open
that I'm looking for I'm looking
everywhere for stuff that we try cutting
it off no way
burn and now I cut it off okay no I
can't get it then shut up
hmm what really that worked that worked
what that that really worked oh my god I
can't believe that actually worked what
was that
I'm beginning to fear my actions I
suddenly imagine a rising up it's
wrangly the rifle
if I burn these roots okay I need to
find a way to get the trunk open maybe
with the bar iron bar I have the metal
bar metal bar iron bar down man
it's a bar
hmm okay there we go
Oh what is that what is that all this
mass come up face okay I've got plant
what the Oh appears to be fastened to
the floor why would I want to move it
anyway I have a bad feeling mother's
[ __ ] damn it oh oh oh
oh I didn't do anything
Oh God give mother [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
number Oh
huh huh huh ah sit outfit or huh oh okay
I'm good all right it's not for me
thank you so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part bye
bye